okay
[Music]
[Music]
all right i always forget what number it
is did we just pass 20 really part of me
feels like we hit 20. last one was yeah
last one was 20. so it's 21.
on point q a is now old enough to shrink
in the united states
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and
welcome to ask mkbhd version 21. uh
just
turned the mic on hey what is up guys
mkbhd here and welcome to ask mkbhd
version 21. we've done one every month
of this year so far this is number 10 of
the 12 for 2017. it's october i reached
out on twitter asked you guys what you
wanted to know
and these are your best questions
thoughts on the demonetization situation
and how has it affected you so i think
i've touched on this before but i've
been almost completely unaffected by the
demonetization problems that a lot of
youtubers have been having in the past
year or two but just because it's not
happening to me doesn't mean it's not
happening and just because it's
happening to some other people doesn't
mean it's happening to everyone a couple
days ago casey neistat made a great
video kind of outlining the entire
situation about the communication from
the youtube team and the relationship
between youtube itself and the community
and the problems people have been having
it's worth a watch i agree with a lot of
what he says in that video but the main
thing to get out of that is that the the
biggest problem we have is there's not a
lot of communication between youtube and
us youtubers about what those problems
are and a lot of what casey talks about
in his video is about the value of
youtubers to youtube about how we will
leave at the drop of a hat and go
somewhere else if there's a bigger
audience or a better monetization
solution but i think the problem is
youtube is the biggest audience has been
for years and will be for a long time so
actually don't see youtubers leaving
youtube anytime soon no matter how bad
this monetization situation gets because
it's still the biggest audience so
anyway i have a lot of thoughts about
that but essentially i've been
unaffected i'm just keeping my ear to
the ground and keeping a finger on the
pulse and trying to figure out what
other people think too which dual camera
setup do you prefer most one with a
secondary monochrome or one with the
telephoto lens uh between those two i
would definitely pick the telephoto lens
or just any additional focal length over
the monochrome sensor i've tested a
couple phones that have the second
monochrome camera to add detail and
enhance the photos but a lot of times
those aren't good cameras in the first
place so uh it doesn't really make much
of a difference to me so i'll take that
v30 with the wide-angle camera i'll take
the iphone or the note or whatever with
the second portrait camera that's cool i
also really appreciate the way google's
done it and i'll talk about it in the
full review with a single camera for
portrait mode but that's another story
if you reach down what would you rather
have in your pocket red or iphone 10.
well i do have
two pockets so if i reach down and
i mean
why not both at this point
[Music]
one of the speakers on the bottom of the
iphone 7 plus and a plus doesn't
actually work
uh could apple have put a headphone jack
there instead
listen the headphone jack is dead
headphone jack's not coming back we just
kind of have to embrace it and move on
quickly but seriously i've definitely
mentioned it before yes we're in that
like awkward stage in between everyone
having headphone jacks and nobody
needing them because wireless is so good
uh but to keep wishing for it to come
back is definitely not a productive
exercise
just gonna have to move along any
updates on your professional ultimate
frisbee career what teams are you
playing for and where can we see your
games so it's the off season right now
it's about to be winter the professional
ultimate frisbee season is generally
during the summer and when the summer
rolls around i of course i always tweet
uh where you can see our games when you
can see our games that's the best place
to find that but right now it's the off
season it's more of like college
ultimate and club
ultimate and just other fun stuff la
clippers wins set at 42 and a half over
under
hmm
uh
i'm gonna go with over yeah you know
what i'm optimistic i'm gonna go with
the over on this one but i have to
mention i will be watching rockets games
also now because i'm a chris ball fan
that's the original reason i became a
clippers fan now he's a houston rocket
now i'm watching houston rockets games
what do you think of the soon to be
announced razer phone so you know what
if red can make a smartphone
then i guess it's anyone's ball game
razer bought next bit now they're aiming
to make a smartphone and we'll probably
be seeing that pretty soon i'm excited
for that too obviously next bit has a
little bit of a history but we may or
may not see bits of that in the new
razer phone but razer
is is a gaming peripheral and gaming
device maker right now so i kind of
expect to see a lot of cues from that
sort of stuff in the new smartphone plus
combined with maybe some of the next
bits past it'll be interesting to see
i'll definitely try to cover that when
it comes out zte axon m why do you hate
it it's kind of a cool concept so yeah i
tweeted about this the other day that
zte axon m has come out it's a foldable
smartphone but not really it's more of a
dual screen phone with a hinge in the
middle that just kind of unfolds like
that i agree it's it's a cool concept a
key word being concept but the actual
execution when you look at the final
result
just doesn't look good at all now i can
appreciate trying to one-up samsung
where you kind of you have a feeling
they're going to do some sort of a
foldable display in the near future so
you try to be first to that uh this just
isn't good for anything other than maybe
splitting a movie across two screens it
doesn't do all that much that's useful i
see the demo videos i'll link one below
mr mobile did a great one the verge did
a great one you can mirror the display
across both screens you can extend the
screen across both screens but no matter
how you use it it's just weird having a
big
bezel in the middle of your display so
it's a cool concept yes but if i told
you the price tag you'd probably agree
with me that just doesn't seem like a
good product did you upgrade to the new
monstro 8k
vista vision so look uh
no i haven't gotten it yet
but
it's pretty likely that i will end up
making that move pretty soon for those
of you who don't know the biggest
difference between the new monstro 8k
sensor and the current helium super 35
sensor besides the cheesy new name is
the size of it the super 35 sensor is
smaller than full frame and the
vistavision 8k sensor is a full frame
size sensor that has a lot of
implications as far as what glass you
can use the type of a look you get with
your video and your bokeh and the type
of flexibility you get and you having a
much wider angle lens in a smaller area
it's actually useful for those hands-on
areas i could name a ton of reasons why
i'm excited for the upgrade right now
but long story short yeah that's
probably gonna happen what's your go-to
everyday object to use as a weapon
in a self-defense situation
that makes it seem like i have like an
answer already like a go-to would it be
cheating to say the weapon just because
it's already a weapon that's exactly
what that would be yeah
you could hurt somebody with this it's
mostly metal and it's got sharp edges
and it has a handle
yup that'll do it go to meal after a
game of ultimate that's easy chipotle
for sure can you solve a rubik's cube oh
i don't have one but i i can solve one
face of a rubik's cube i have those
algorithms memorized and i can get the
first row around the face and then i
don't know any of the rest whose vision
of the future will win google or apple
both are focusing on different things
google is software versus apple hardware
that's an interesting question i kind of
think you have to have both obviously
there's advantages with going with
either way apple's ecosystem built
around their super premium hardware is
amazing but on the other end of things
like google being able to improve things
on the fly and add features and have
essentially a modular experience with
their software also has huge advantages
but it's nothing without the hardware
and vice versa so you kind of have to
have both and i think both are realizing
that and trying to build that way apple
is trying to build up their ecosystem to
compete with google's massive ecosystem
of products and google's trying to build
their own hardware build their own
phones like the pixel to compete with
apple's ecosystem hardware where do you
find your awesome glitch funk electro
intro songs seriously i'm in love with
that genre well thank you i don't really
have like one source i always go to for
music but i can tell you that in the
past couple videos the intros you've
been hearing are unreleased tracks from
alta's new album i will link it below
i've heard the whole thing i'm not
allowed to like share that entire thing
but i'm giving you these little sneak
peeks and they're releasing a new track
from that every wednesday again just
click the link it's expanding in
playlist it's amazing anyway i'm going
to end it right there thank you for
tuning in to this quick episode of your
questions and answers it's been fun but
i'm going to get right back to this
review video i'm making and a whole
bunch of other stuff coming up for
october and november it's just that time
of year there's a lot of new products
either way
thanks for watching talk to you guys the
next one
peace
[Music]